let's say that you travel six times a
year so every two months average travel
at least in the us is gonna be two hours
so if you two hour flight six times a
year it's there and back which is four
hours just 24 hours the reason i'm
defining this by hours is because
private jets get price per hour and if
you're curious how much it costs if you
go through a service you can usually get
it for about four thousand dollars an
hour so that's about a hundred thousand
dollars a year wait flying private 100
000 a year i thought it was you had to
be a super duper millionaire no not
really it's 100 a year now do i think
that's really expensive for flights when
the alternative to that is first six
flights could be maybe you know if you
did first class you'd be maybe spending
six grand at worst if you did the last
minute you'd spend like 10 grand so 10
times the price that's the alternative
price flying private is actually really
nice but it's wildly expensive and i
still feel guilty for it